let's get to it and this is a new game i
don't know how often we're going to play
it we've got this selection of prices
right style games we play from time to
time this is loosely based on a more
common cultural game that i can't name
here because one of the words is one of
chris's favorite words start one bench
one cut one that's what we're going to
do negative so negative why i mean we
only get to say one positive what
because i'm not saying it's you i'm
blaming stats i'm blaming pat pete
demolitis
all those guys in the back room i mean
bench one and cut one are both negatives
you know so we only get to say a little
positive it's very hard here i don't
like this
so you you're more accustomed to the
other game that has i guess two that
would be positive and one that would be
very negative extremely exactly
extremely negative right all right start
one bench one cut one tom brady drew
brees philip rivers
uh i'm gonna
i'm going to start tom brady i'm going
to bench drew brees and i'm going to cut
phillip rivers that's how i'm going to
go there you know i just i'm still that
easy wasn't that yes that was easy
i know that was an easy one i'm more
worried about some of the other ones i
see on this list farther down that are
they're not they're not easy but do you
agree would you go that order what would
you do
yeah i think that that's right
yeah breeze and brazilian you're not
sure no no no no no
my only hesitation
now i agree because i think
brees
would take to being the backup better
than rivers would i think that rivers as
anything other than the starter is a guy
that you would want to kill you wouldn't
want him around i mean you heard that
the rumblings when there was chatter
about maybe the chargers drafting
somebody and he reacted very negatively
i mean it's that right he's got that
very intense passion and that fire but
that is also coming from the framework
of i'm your guy
and if you tell me i'm not your guy then
we have a problem so i think i think
you're right i don't want philip rivers
around as anything about my starter and
brees would be an excellent backup a
great team player and he'd do everything
he could to get the starter ready and
brady's still the guy who would be the
starter out of those three see that that
wasn't bad let's move on to this it
wasn't bad all right start one bench one
cut one melvin gordon
devonte freeman todd gurley
okay i'm gonna go start melvin gordon
bench todd gurley
cut devonte freeman uh first off melvin
gordon yeah there's some injury issues
there but man when melvin gordon got
going last year you know he you you see
he's capable of being a true workhorse
he his body's in better shape than todd
gurley's todd gurley i think it's
perfect for the bench i mean that's kind
of what we saw him do last year a little
bit you know you count his reps a little
bit maintain his body and then you know
when he does get in there he's he can
still fly straight away and then devonta
freeman's a guy i got questions about in
general going forward he's been beat up
he's not a real big guy
uh so yeah he's gonna have to find
somewhere else to revive his career
which he actually is gonna have to do in
real life too i'm going to disagree with
you on this one i i okay john freeman
but i say start todd gurley you don't
have to keep him on the field he's your
guy though he's your main guy because i
think he presents
a greater game planning dilemma for an
opposing defense than melvin gordon does
if you use him sparingly you still have
to account for him being on the field
from time to time what do we do when
todd gurley is on the field i'm not
saying he's on the field for 70 snaps
and i'm not saying he should get 20
touches if you manage his workload when
he's on the field he's the guy where
he's the red dot player right he's the
guy you better know where he is and what
he's doing and you better account for
him or he's going to burn you even if
he's only burning you in smaller doses
yeah that's fine i mean i know what your
your logic you're saying there but i
want my work workhorse to be the starter
and i'd look right now at melvin gordon
being the the workhorse where gurley he
comes in and oh we got this little
creative toss sweep where if he gets it
you know on the edge he could go 50
yards oh we got a play action screen or
a screenplay that's kind of how i viewed
it and yes i am concerned about gurley's
knee i mean hey the rams were we get it
we saw it in his play last year and i
know a few times that i came on the show
on you know after watching my film and
doing all that where i said yeah there
was reluctance reluctance to cut off the
bad knee too so it shows up so that's
why i would just rather bring him off
the bench let him ride the bike get warm
and then go out there and hit it
now it gets more complicated i know to
the receivers this one stats what are
you doing to us
killing me
amari cooper deandre hopkins start one
bench one cut one really
really that this is this is the one that
caught my attention right yeah all right
i'm starting de'andre hopkins uh yeah i
am i think he's the best one of the
group he's the most reliable he's always
healthy he's tough you know uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna bench steph on diggs i'm gonna
put him over there
and then i'm going to cut amari cooper
it's not easy one here but i'm going to
kind of mark hoover really more going
with the cutting of amari cooper just
because of being banged up and injured a
little bit and
i feel like
it's tough between him and diggs's
attitude i'd be a little worried about
either one of them but i don't know if
amari cooper is going to react real well
being a a bench warmer either
well i think both of them would accept
the fact that they should be
behind deandre hopkins
right right but but i
we've seen we've seen more flash points
from diggs than we have from cooper he
went awol on the team last year after
the bears game and you know i i i have
and we look stefan diggs is one of our
favorites he's great when he's on the
show with the super bowl and he's had
some great moments for the vikings who
have some great moments for the bills
and i think the positives outweigh the
negatives but you know even
there are plenty of receivers who
as long as the team wins they don't care
right remember that week one game
vikings beat the falcons they threw the
ball 10 times
yeah most players would be like we're
fine with that as long as we win i don't
think diggs was fine with that and i i
think i think that i think diggs is a
guy if you're not going to start him you
don't want him on the team you don't
want to put him in a in a back-up roll
because he's going to be a pain in your
butt
more pain in your butt than amari cooper
if he's on the bench so that that's and
and you know i don't know i
and i don't know is mark cooper better
when he's healthy he is better where
every week we have probably but if he's
healthy right yes yeah
this one was the biggest one
without a doubt is the toughest one but
that's what would concern me too is
omari cooper's health and you know again
too
you know we saw maury cooper as much as
he's kind of like righted himself in
dallas and seemed to have changed his
image when things weren't great in
oakland yeah he didn't say a lot of
things but i think he went around with a
lot of bad bad body language and showed
that he wasn't happy that way and that
he wasn't comfortable there in that
organization and that environment too so
you got to take that into account too
and also hey let's not forget i know you
want to blame diggs after that chicago
week thielen's the one that opened the
doors he opened the whammy on kirk
cousins that whole week and i think that
opened the floodgates and gave diggs
confidence to act up himself too
and here's the other thing too if we
take their contracts as they currently
are and their expectations for the
future
sure you know
do you i mean
do you make deandre hopkins a cap casual
if he wants 22 million a year and just
go with diggs and cooper
well it's a it's a good question you're
right uh but
no not right now deandre hopkins is he's
kind of in the zone he's in the prime of
his career right now one he can get open
you know two when he's not open he's
still open he's one of those guys and i
think that's you know special there's
only a handful of them in football
all right next one pass rushers
defensive lineman jadavian clowney chris
jones shaq barrett start one bench one
cut one
man i mean this one might be worse than
the one before all right i'm starting
chris jones i mean chris jones to me is
one of the best defensive players in
football uh he is a game disrupter
man
you know i love gideon clowney but i'm
going to put shaquille barrett on the
bench all right because shaquille
barrett is first off he's been on the
bench there he's shown that he's a team
guy uh and jiddevian clowney yeah i'm
gonna cut him because of the injury
history and i don't think he's the type
of guy that could deal with being on the
bench either and he might cause a ruckus
that way and and uh not be happy in that
situation
yeah i mean if i had a healthy genevieve
clowny i'd start him every game the
problem is i'm not going to get a
healthy diving clowny and and as you
point out he had the micro fracture
surgery on his knee after his season he
he injured that knee the first game of
his rookie season he kind of landed
awkwardly on the turf at the stadium in
houston and uh and that was that and
he's been fighting that ever since so i
i agree with you chris jones is the guy
you have to have on the field all the
time for what he can do as a run stopper
and as a pass rusher and barrett i think
would accept the role as a backup
rotational situational pass rusher and
janavian sorry we love you but we can't
count on you to be here so we're going
to go with jones and barrett instead um
let's squeeze in one more here this
one's intriguing oh
start one bench one cut one eric
armstead deforest buckner and the 13th
overall draft pick which is what the
49ers got from the colts in exchange for
buckner who
they decided not to sign to a long-term
deal because he wanted too much money so
they signed eric armstead instead
i'm gonna go buckner and start him
because he's the best player of the
group i mean he's he's you know he's one
of the better defensive players in all
football he's a game changer that way
i'm gonna put eric armstead on the bench
and you know as much as i like the 13th
pick in the draft and the possibilities
they're not proven commodities like the
other two are i mean deforest buckner
yeah he's in the combo for one of the
best yes but you want you're worried
about the money that's what you're
talking about armstead is about you're
getting combined you're gonna get a guy
for five years you get a guy for five
years cheap with that 13th overall pick
okay great but what if you get a bust i
mean i could show you some 13 overall
picks or or crap the last few years so
you know that how do you feel about your
money that you saved now or would you
rather have the really good player
i i don't i i would go buckner start
13th overall draft pick bench eric
armstead cut because that that
those draft picks before they are
exercised you know how it goes the teams
act like they are
they are like untouchable sacred objects
because every pick can become a hall of
fame player
an unused pick is like an unscratched
lottery ticket that potentially is going
to give you 20 million dollars right and
until you scratch it off you don't know
what's behind that that annoying silver
paint that that never wants to come off
all the way um
before it's scratched it can be anything
and i think before that pick is used it
can be anyone it can be a hall of famer
it can be a guy that makes your career
as a gm so i'm not throwing that thing
out the window although the colts were
very happy to do that to get deforest
buckner and they're paying him 21
million per year and i think that the
the mindset is
that's kind of a wasteland this year
like there's not a guaranteed great
player at number 13. so what the hell
let's go ahead well yeah that we know is
going to be great
yeah so i think that's exactly what they
did and i think they looked at their
defensive line and said we need a
difference maker and we're not going to
find one at 13 this year so yeah i mean
that would be part of that discussion if
we were really running a football team
and we had to make these type of
decisions you got to look at the roster
what's available in free agency what's
available in the draft and then you have
to try to figure it out from there and
yes sitting at 13 in this draft you know
i don't know if there was a difference
maker like deforest buckner that you
could guarantee say okay yeah i'm going
to be able to get him at 13. i think
some of those guys might be gone by the
time they're picking and then it's kind
of no man's land for a while before the
next group of really good different you
know really the other guys that you
would pick at defensive tackle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports